[Music]
dang kids
never cleaning up their toys before
bedtime
who still buys their kids jacks in this
century
the kids even know what these things are
for anymore
oh what could possibly inflict this much
foot pain
[Music]
i really wish kids would just stick to
minecraft
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that proves to you that you
don't need to be afraid of monsters in
your closet because the real world is
filled with so
so much worse today we're talking about
the pixar classic monsters inc if you
don't remember it monster's inc
isn't just the name of the movie it's
actually a power company that gets its
electricity by harvesting energy from
children's screams
the business model of this place is
simple use a door portal to have a
monster
enter a child's bedroom through the
closet do something terrifying and watch
as the canisters of scream energy
fill up except as it turns out their
business model isn't working as well as
it used to
kids these days apparently are growing
up too fast and losing their fear of
monsters which is
kind of a weird premise isn't it i mean
i get that children are the ones that
are supposed
to be scared of monsters but if you
think about it the people who would be
most disturbed by a monster coming out
of their closet door would probably be
the ones who
don't believe in monsters in the first
place right i mean not only do you
suddenly have this terrifying beast
roaring at you but heck now your entire
world view has just been
shattered in front of your eyes i guess
existential dread and questioning
reality just doesn't pack the same punch
as a blood-curdling scream huh anyway as
we start our movie business is bad at
monsters inc
and things are doubly bad for star
employee james p
sullivan aka sully when one day he
accidentally takes his work home with
him he's spending a late night at the
factory when a human girl wanders
through the door
and into the monster realm boo causes
quite a ruckus since as it turns out
monsters are just as afraid of us as we
are of them
sully with the help of his pal mike
wazowski works to return her home and
along the way
loki learns how to become a parent
seriously coming back to this movie now
that i have a kid there are so many
scenes that hit differently
except for this one yeah that moment
when the two-year-old toddler looks
sully in the eyes with the expression
that says it's time to locate the
nearest restroom
most fictional thing that happens in
this movie forget door portals and
monster companies if you're getting that
look from a two-year-old it's already
too late
don't ask me how i know that animated
hijinks ensue and after foiling a plot
to kidnap kids to farm screams out of
them which i
totally overlooked the first time i
watched this movie and his genuine
nightmare fuel we learned that kids
laughter is actually the thing that
produces more energy than kids screams
so in addition to saving the day for boo
mike and sully actually saved the day
for monsters inc as well whose new
laughter-based business model not only
leads to a happier world for little kids
around the world but also for the city
of monstropolis but let's talk brass
tacks here alright finding out that
laughter provides more energy than
screams makes for a feel-good ending but
just how real is it like what is
monstropolis
really running on here how could a
scream-based energy system work
and is there an explanation for why
laughter may just be more efficient well
believe it or not but for as fictional
as this world's rules might seem
i think i've actually cracked the
mechanics of how this whole thing works
so
step aside elon musk here comes elon
matpat to show the world our next green
energy source emotion
while the idea of screams and or
laughter serving as a power source might
seem fanciful you might be surprised to
find out that it actually squares with
real world science screams and laughter
like all
sounds are the result of energy
vibrating air particles or
any other material that the sound is
traveling through those vibrating air
particles are a form of kinetic energy
so if you have a device that's somehow
able to capture that kinetic energy you
would actually be in business
and wouldn't you know it you don't have
to have a special engineering degree
from monsters university to figure this
out a group of 11th grade students at
philippine science high school made
headlines when they created their own
proof of concept
a gadget that's like a speaker but in
reverse instead of taking electrical
power and converting it into sound waves
like your headphones do
they take sound waves and convert it
into electrical power they take sound
waves to vibrate a magnet and coil
system which creates a flow of electrons
and not just a measly flow of electrons
here people it's enough to power
a 5 watt led light bulb apparently this
idea won him a silver award at a big
science convention to which i say
silver are you kidding me they generated
electricity from
sound i mean what did the gold medal
winner do create nuclear fusion
meanwhile all the rest of us are making
baking soda volcanoes anyway
this silver metal idea gives us a place
to start when it comes to how screams
and laughter can possibly provide
energy one thing that should be fairly
obvious is that louder sounds provide
more energy
loudness measured in decibels is
literally a measure of how intense the
sound waves are which directly
correlates with how much
energy they're carrying except it's here
that we run into our first problem
human laughter usually registers at
about 65 decibels
screaming registers at about 90. while
that might not sound like that much of a
difference it's actually significant the
decibel scale that we use to measure the
intensity of sound
is logarithmic i'll spare you all the
math but it basically means that a 90
decibel scream is
actually 56 times more intense than a 65
decibel laugh
not looking too good for laughter based
power there maybe the monster villains
planning to kidnap the kids and strap
them to chairs we're onto something
or maybe there's something else at work
here maybe sound
isn't the only thing being produced when
you laugh or scream these extreme
emotions
are experiences that engage our whole
bodies after all so we need to consider
screams versus laughter as a whole
metabolic experience luckily real world
researchers have done a surprising
amount of study on this exact topic one
found that laughter
in general can burn anywhere between one
and three calories per minute
but fear also does a fine job of kicking
your metabolism into high gear
a separate study at the university of
westminster found that people watching
horror movies were burning an average of
1.25 calories per minute from being in a
heightened fear state
here's johnny
you've been sitting there all day ma i'm
exercising here
phew i'm really working up a sweat in
fact that 1.25 calories per minute
burned from fear is actually a bit low
because that was the average for the
whole movie
rather than periods of fear intense
enough for a blood-curdling primal
scream of terror which means that yet
again
screams have the slight advantage over
laughs but i feel like there's a big
thing we're overlooking here after all
we're shown in the prequel movie
monsters university that the monsters
have the ability to access all sorts of
locations in the human world yet they
choose to focus
on children's bedrooms sure screaming
kids can hit a pretty high decibel level
but let's be honest if the monsters only
cared about harvesting energy from
something really loud they could just
take a door that led to like a waterfall
or an airport or something likewise when
it comes to burning calories those one
to three calories per minute
is tiny you want to harvest that much
energy from the human world you just
grab a log and you burn it you'll
release 4780 calories worth of energy
more than you'd get from thousands of
minutes of terrified screaming
and a log ain't gonna fight back clearly
there's something else going on here and
i think the answer is neurochemical
dopamine has historically been known as
the brain's pleasure chemical but that's
a bit simple of an explanation more
recent research suggests that it's
better described as the motivational
chemical it gives you the impulse that
you really want to go out and do
something
studies show that playing video games
actually doubles the levels of dopamine
in your brain which fun fact is about
the same increase that you get from
um how do i put this snogging very
passionately
single on valentine's day no worries
friends you have video games to keep you
company your brain will be just as happy
the rest of your body and wouldn't you
know it but activities known to increase
dopamine levels in the brain
include laughter and surprisingly enough
screaming
in fact the simple act of screaming by
itself is enough to trigger a dopamine
release which means that all those
companies selling scream therapy pillows
actually have a little leg to stand on
this method of yelling to trigger a
neurochemical release and relieve stress
briefly became a popular therapeutic
technique during the 1970s i say briefly
because as it turns out the more you do
it the less effective at releasing
dopamine it becomes and there it is my
friends
that is our missing piece that's the
reason why monsters inc seems to be
doing so poorly these days remember
their business model revolves around
having a daily rotation of doors to kids
bedrooms that they repeatedly visit and
the more you keep scaring the same kids
the less
dopamine each of their screams is gonna
release kids these days
they just don't get scared like you used
to yeah mr waternews you're right you
know why kids aren't getting scared like
they used to it's because the more you
keep scaring them the less
effective their screams are but you know
what doesn't get less effective with
repetition
laughter while the primal scream therapy
technique has now fallen out of favor
there's plenty of scientific research
indicating that laughter does make for
effective therapeutic treatment
releasing dopamine into your system
and unlike screams whose effectiveness
decreases with repetition
laughter may actually increase dopamine
levels the more that you laugh a study
by researchers at the university
hospital of zurich found that people
with higher dopamine levels were more
likely to laugh when exposed to humorous
stimuli
and laughter led to higher dopamine
levels in the future thereby leading to
a self-perpetuating cycle where the more
you laugh and generate dopamine the
easier it becomes for your brain to
laugh and generate more dopamine the
next time you encounter something funny
in other words you could not ask for a
better and more sustainable source of
energy
than laughter it really is the best
medicine the benefits of laughter are
both
short and long-term which is great news
for me considering my addiction to whose
line is it anyway
it's also great news for monsters inc
who by transitioning to laughter as a
power source have just found something a
whole lot more effective and a whole lot
more sustainable than harvesting screams
but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and you know what's not a
laughing matter you know what truly is
scary the fact that monsters inc
is not on netflix yep the old mouse has
taken all of its movies and thrown em
into the disney plus vault that you can
keep open
as long as you keep paying at least in
most cases that's how it's going down
you see monsters inc is available to
stream on netflix in
egypt but i don't live in egypt you say
to which i reply you can make your
internet look like it's coming from
egypt using our sponsor for today's
episode
nordvpn in two clicks you change your
region and suddenly netflix egypt is
available to you meaning you suddenly
have access to monsters inc
as well as other pixar classics that
aren't streamable here in the us
like wall-e and toy story with nordvpn
you unlock a truly global
internet so region locking becomes a
thing of the past nord allows you to
watch practically anything you want with
only one streaming service and that is
gonna save you
money a lot of it right now a disney
plus subscription
alone is seven dollars a month and
that's not including all the other
services that you might have
subscribing to a two-year plan with nord
is practically half the price but
unlocking
all the content and that's not all nord
is doing for you nord is also protecting
you while it does that it's easy to
forget but nord is all about security
encrypting your data so you stay
anonymous online
unprotected p2p sharing and downloading
exposes your ip address to others
unless of course you're using nord and
with super fast servers 24 7 customer
support and up to six simultaneous
connections
nord ain't slowing you down while you're
doing your streaming and it's protecting
you while you do it so get yourself
a huge discount on a two-year plan of
nordvpn nordvpn.com
film theory f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y
and when you use my code film theory you
get an extra month absolutely free so
protect yourself
watch monsters inc without having to pay
the mouse and support a sponsor that's
been supporting us for years
nordvpn link is in the top line of the
description and i'll see you all
next week and cut